alors on revient à des choses un petit
peu plus grave le 11 septembre
d'ailleurs vous ne pouvez écrire là
dessus que le 23 septembre
et c'est là que vous dites que
l'intelligence progressiste excuses tous
les terrorismes parce que le crime
originel c'est la domination
s'accaparent du moment où on a été
dominés où on est dominé ça donne droit
à tout et on le voit bien si vous voulez
c'est aussi le problème
israélo-palestinien soit on le pense
comme un affrontement entre deux
légitimités soit on le pense en termes
d'oppresseurs face à un opprimé donc le
prix mais est innocent même quand il est
coupable tandis que le brasseur il est
coupable
même quand il est innocent toni negri le
pape enfin le l'un des papes de
l'antimondialisation donne un entretien
au monde et il dit oh écoutez je
j'aurais vraiment préféré
j'aurais vraiment préféré que l'avion
qui devait tomber sur la maison blanche
tombe sur la maison blanche
malheureusement ça n'a pas été le cas ça
aurait été vraiment mieux que ces avions
qui sont tombées sur les twin towers
parce que dans les twin towers il y
avait des travailleurs et même des
clandestins mes ennemis ce sont les
amplis les impériaux donc les
clandestins il faut les sauver mais tous
les autres ils peuvent ils peuvent
crever ça serait bien
donc vous rendez compte dans quel
univers ce progressisme nous conduit
exactement l'univers dont toute une
partie de l'europe vient hélas et la
mauvaise
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait pour les
frites non on essaye de faire beaucoup
de choses on essaie d'y voler moi je ne
sais pas je sur ce je crois qu'il y a
des choses à dire et des choses à faire
pour la paix israélo palestinienne pour
la paix n'était pas pour cette pétition
mais pour la paix je suis je
dès qu'une ouverture se présente on
essaye de la saisir et quand on choisit
une courbe après quand on choisit une
cause
on lui apporte encore une fois un
soutien conditionnel
je vous donne un exemple un exemple on
soutient il faut que les palestiniens
est un état et quand on voit quand on
voit à la télévision ça c'est des images
de la télévision
les collaborateurs traîner dans la rue
ou l'inde entre ce qu'ils appelaient les
collaborateurs des gens qui ont espionné
pour israël ou un autre pendu à un
pylône et les gens
la voiture et les gens se baladent sous
les on-dit quoi on dit c'est la faute de
l'oppresseur non c'est un problème très
grave et si vous dites aux palestiniens
c'est affreux
et bien évidemment il se conduire en
autrement et quand ils auront un état
ce sera un état viable pour eux en
revanche si vous ne leur dit rien ça
donnera ce qu'a donné le soutien des
progressistes au fln
c'est à dire l'algérie de maintenant
donc tirons les leçons de l'histoire
pour avoir un coeur intelligent
attendez je reprends ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure c'est à dire que quand
quand juliette dit l'algérie faut qu'on
y pense c'est notre faute ce qui se
passe finalement s'en est mal occupé
après l'indépendance etc
de chaque côté il ya des raisons mais
pour les comprendre ces raisons il faut
essayer en tout cas les comprendre
peut-être parce que je sais que les
bonnes questions pour y arriver mais est
ce que le repentir peut servir de
politique
le reporter ça veut dire quoi dire
pardon je crois que quand on a on a on a
tué son père n'a tué sa mère on a tué
ses enfants je crois que si l'autre côté
on entend par bon ben c'est pas si mal
que ça parce que c'est pas toujours les
mêmes qui disent pardon d'une certaine
façon par m moi j'ai jamais entendu le
fln demandé pardon pour les 150
milliards qui ont été tuées en 60 de oui
oui je crois que c'est des deux côtés de
toutes les façons ça peut pas être que
d'un seul côté je crois qu'on est sur
cette terre c'est on a du mal à vivre
ensemble dessus mais abandonnée si on
fait pas d un certain effort même si ces
dits difficiles et je comprends pas ce
que les juifs ont comme on a quand même
ont quand même vécu l'horreur et c'est
l'horreur aujourd'hui aussi bien pour
les deux ils sont là alors je donne un
mouchoir
parce que je trouve de blu ray en tête
et que ce soit 100 de temps après après
la guerre la seconde guerre mondiale et
certains juifs réagissent comme ça je
trouve que c'est ce qu'a fait tant
d'années a merveilleusement c'est que
après avoir été opprimés pendant des
années des années il a su ouvrir une
porte
je suis désolé c'est vous qui le voyait
plus
[Applaudissements]
non mais c'est pas grave de pleurer ça
arrive
voilà comment on apprend à pleurer et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater
le in a l'habitude abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu